thing
right software is something else in
which sense does software exist
and the best answer that i have so far
discovered is that software is a
physical law
the physical law says if you for
instance arrange matter in this
particular way the following thing will
happen
and this is true for software right so
no matter where you are in the universe
in which universe you are if you uh
produce the following functional
arrangement of things the following
thing will happen this is what software
is about so the programmer in some sense
is discovering by constructing certain
very peculiar circumstances a very
specific physical law
and
i just want to interrupt that's really
cool
that's really cool i really like that
idea
i want to make sure i'm sorry for it i
want to make sure i'm following you
you're proposing that software has the
same kind of ontological status as
physical law exactly
wow that's really really cool i hadn't
that's cool keep going please i just
wanted to yeah that's very cool yeah i
thought when i stumbled on this insight
that it was a good insight that
basically started
to make sense right because it's an
apparent pattern in the interaction of
many parts yeah
yeah really that's very good i like that
that's very good that's very good
so uh this also means uh because i think
that mental states are best understood
as software states
that the ontological status of our
mental states is different from the
ontological states of uh the one that we
attribute to physical things
so this has to do with the notion of
identity of a mental state
that is similar to the identity of a
physical law which means it's not this
point wise identity yeah yeah it's a
functional identity yeah yeah and uh now
let's go back to uh so the original
chinese room argument is very simplistic
in a sense like it's a children's story
myth that searle himself doesn't believe
in and it's an argument that is by
absurd when he repeats it today made in
bad faith the seal is affiliated with
this his actual contributions to
philosophy have been largely an
extension of
austin's speech act theory that are
boring and wouldn't give praise to fame
but the
chinese womb is somebody that everybody
understands because it interfaces with
certain intuitions and it's an intuition
pump
and if you disassemble these intuitions
and try to make them more distinct and
more clear then many of them fall apart
and searle is aware because he's not
stupid he's a very smart individual of
many of the ways in which they fall
apart but he is still repeating the
original chinese room argument because
it's his brand
so it's it's not because he believes in
it and if you actually read his uh this
work he is aware of many of the country
arguments and he knows that he needs to
go into a few levels of complications to
have an interesting argument and to have
an interesting case that he's making so
the uh superficial level of the chinese
room argument is maybe not that
interesting a slight extension that is
more interesting is the chinese brain
argument that so is also aware of and
the chinese brain argument suggests that
instead of having this library with
books in it in which you execute the
algorithm we use a different
implementation of that whole thing
and instead what we do is we take uh
and mechanization of the neuron itself
so if we accept that what the brain is
doing is facilitated by the interaction
of neurons
the u1 has to follow certain rules in
order to make that happen and maybe we
can spell out these rules in our thought
experiment and then we assign a chinese
person to a neuron
and we maybe we need a few more we maybe
need 86 billion chinese people in
instead of 1.4 but it's a thought
experiment so not a problem at all and
now instead of neurons we have chinese
which follow these walls or we could use
machines instead of the chinese that are
following these rules
and so uh
i think that this matching between a
neuron and a chinese person is not
completely absurd on the face of it of
course it would be much larger and we
blow it up
and now uh sir would say of course the
chinese brain doesn't have the necessary
and sufficient conditions to produce a
conscious mind and then
access to meaning so it doesn't change
anything whether the chinese room or the
chinese brain is performing these
operations the chinese brain is still
not able to to speak chinese because the
individual identities of the chinese
people and their knowledge does not
interfere in any way with their
emulation of the functionality of
individual neurons
so now if we have established this case
where sir would say the chinese brain is
not conscious but your brain is
conscious let's see where is the
boundary between those two systems so
let's take your brain blow it up until a
person and the neuron have roughly the
same size so change the time so it
doesn't matter how much the chinese need
to talk to each other to make the new
world functionality happening and set
messages back and forth so let's keep
this an identity and now we take
basically take your neurons and uh cell
accepts that neurons are facilitating
mental activity he is not a
mysteriousness or so and he doesn't know
how the brain does it but he agrees that
the brain is doing it he is a
physicalist in a sense
so now uh
let's replace step by step the neurons
by some other machinery for instance
chinese people or machines that have
neural lag functionality
and so at some point says this loses the
ability to be conscious so the
consciousness is drowning out of the
system
by this replacement process
and what this means is that swirl has a
strong
anti-functionalist position he basically
says that the function of the individual
parts is not producing the essential
behavior they're somehow in essence he's
an essentialist
and i don't know how to get essentialism
to work
because nobody has ever seen an essence
right we can talk about an essence but
it's epi phenomena
and the problem with epi phenomenalism
is is the following epiphany is if we go
back to our dualism from the beginning
of conversation today
it's the idea that there is maybe a read
access from the mind
where the mind is reading physics but no
right access from the mind into physics
so it's not violating the causal closure
of physics
but there is a problem with epi
phenomenalism and that is
uh the phenomenal experience that you
don't think you can explain in the
physical mechanism is not driving
anything of what you are saying
including your utterances of beliefs so
when an epiphany says but i feel and
this cannot be explained by physics this
is caused by physics right because the
epiphanialist has to move their mouths
or move their fingers to
express the statement and all these
movements are caused by an entirely
mechanical process the uh true feeling
which happens next to their physical
mechanical part of their mind the
philosophical zombie and so on is not
driving any behavior so basically there
would be this locked in epithelialism
that would helplessly watching their
body make statements in favor or against
epiphanicalism but there would be no
causal relationship between the
epithelialism so no epithelialist is an
epi phenomenalist because they have
phenomenal experience that cannot be
explained by physics that is the issue
here
and so if sir goes down that path he
goes down to a very inconvenient place
that i don't know how to resolve